so
and and what I see guys and just just
general Trends is women really like
typically what happens is they come out
years later they come out and my
question is to those women why would you
wait years okay I'll give you a week
I'll give you two weeks I'll even maybe
give you a month
but
uh 10 years later now he's an abuser 10
years later now he's a rapist
um and until I see police reports and
substantial evidence proving these
claims I I just and I think it's
actually wrong and I think the news
outlets should be held accountable for
reporting on stories with zero evidence
I think they should be held accountable
for labeling a guy a criminal without
telling two sides of the story and guys
you know this is what happened to
Stephen Crowder in front of our eyes you
know I'm gonna be doing a stream on him
either tonight or tomorrow very similar
it's on the right and the left